[Music]  when i was young  astronauts were like god  well when you were young  countries existed  [Music]  commander wagner  [Music]  ruby came to ground control ground  control do you read  does anybody hear us  anyone  you need to lie down this fog is toxic  nobody can survive this  is works  the algae where  i can survive  fought so hard for a planet that doesn't  exist anymore they can't be dead  [Music]  hello  we don't have much oxygen left these  people need our help if we could bring  your algae down there we could save 300  lives  flying down are you out of your mind so  what we do nothing we just watch them  die  have you gone completely crazy in that  lab you don't get to talk to me about  crazy mister  either you come with us or you stay  come on  you really think they would give you  their algae if it was the other way  around  it's your job to keep us alive  you're a good person you know that this  is right  [Music]  you